what's poppin rockstars my name is mt
and episode 3 of loki finally gave us
the proper look at the lethal
lovely lady loki that we've all been
waiting for and it turns out she wasn't
even lady loki at all
and that she is in fact the lokemon
sylvia lauffy
tear that has been teased in an earlier
episode as well as the end credits of
some international versions of the show
and good god can this woman fight
like holy [ __ ] she for sure came to the
tva
to kick names and take ass but
unfortunately the only ass that she
really got to take was an ass by the
name
of loki laufen all the way to the doomed
moon of lamentus 1 where sylvie opens up
a little and teases us with a few short
comments into her past
you know like the fact that she knew
that she was adopted at an early age
i knew i was adopted what they told you
she barely remembers her mother i barely
remember her just blips of a dream at
this point and that she's been fighting
the tva for her entire life
when did you get so paranoid i guess it
must have started when i spent my entire
life running from the immediate fascists
you work for
but we the greedy nerds of the internet
doth declare that this is not enough
god's damn it
we want answers about sylvie's past like
who was sylvie's mother anyway
and why did sylvie's parents decide to
tell her that she was adopted so early
how did she become a robe berry in the
first place
what brand of hair dye does she use the
people have to know
but before i continue i want to thank
newm for sponsoring this video and take
your free
30-second quiz using the link in the
description and get started today
lucky for us marvel studios knows that
we are thirsty hoes for that nerd info
so they just dropped a new silvie
featurette that could help us
good people of the speculation nation
unlock the secrets to her past so
let us theorize as to what could have
happened before the gory days of this
badass witch
my nerd babies so in the latest episode
while the two loki are on their train
date
loki talks fondly about his mother
frigga how kind of a person she was and
that she was the person that originally
taught him magic this is very much in
line with a deleted scene from for the
dark world where frigga actually reveals
that the reason why she taught loki to
be such a proficient magic user was so
loki could be equal and not inferior to
the powerhouses that were odin and thor
and then loki of course shows off some
of that fireworks magic that frigga did
for loki as a kid however the way silby
reacts to loki's fireworks and his past
relationship with his mother
suggests that she can't really relate to
loki's upbringing and when you consider
the facts that a
she barely remembers her own mother and
b she had to teach herself magic
i'm willing to bet that sylvie and loki
have two completely different mothers
leaving the most likely candidate for
silvi's mother in my opinion to be none
other than the goddess of death herself
queen hella hellerson the first or
should i say the worst do you just
the worst i mean think about it in thor
ragnarok we learned that odin and hella
spent their quality daddy-daughter time
bathing in the blood of their enemies as
they went and conquered the nine realms
you know before grabbing some
ice cream on the way home what if sylvie
came from a universe where odin perishes
during these conquests before she was
born
leaving hella as the next ruler of
asgard this would mean when laufey gets
greedy and attacks midgard in sylvie's
reality
instead of odin adopting lauffy's child
as his own to hopefully one day serve as
a key to peace between asgard and
yotenan it was the vicious hella that
takes in
sylvie as her prize like a spoil of war
possibly for the purpose of setting
sylvie up to be a future mean ass
governess of yotenheim
keeping those naginati frost giants in
line you know on behalf of hela's ever
expanding asgardian empire and this
video is brought to you by
noom noom is a different new way to get
healthy lose weight
and achieve your goals using proven
cognitive behavioral therapy practices
nume arms you with the wisdom and
guidance you need to practice making
more thoughtful choices every day
nume helps you learn how your mind works
and the why behind the decisions you
make
learning not dieting is what leads to
real lasting change
nume is a behavior change innovator
using psychology and science to help
people live
the healthy fulfilling lives they
deserve by combining the power of
artificial intelligence
mobile tech and psychology with the
empathy of personal coaches
nume helps people live healthier lives
by changing their long-term habits
cognitive behavior therapy is about
behavior change and proven
long-term results and the new program
has a lot of cool tools including an
exercise and food tracker and these
short interactive daily lessons that
help you
re-examine your behaviors and it's all
personalized to the user now i
personally found the lesson about
distortions quite powerful because it
was all about
the things that we tell ourselves that
prevent us from making progress
like people will judge you for not
eating a salad or eating a cupcake and
your entire day is ruined and nume
explains how these thought distortions
can affect your health and provide you
with the tactics and tools to avoid and
counteract them in the future
take your free 30 second quiz using the
link in the description to get started
today
in this scenario hello would not feel a
single need to hide the truth from
sylvie because
frankly she doesn't really give a [ __ ]
about her because if you think back to
thor 1
odin specifically tells loki that the
reason why he hid the truth of his
parentage from him
was to preserve his feelings and to make
him feel as an equal to his brother but
hell i don't give a damn about that [ __ ]
she was probably like guess what you're
not my daughter
you're a frost giant and i'm gonna make
you fight by my side forever
so i'm gonna teach you how to murder now
and that's how sylvie's been able to
survive all this time because she's been
taught
how to be a warrior at an early age by
her ruthless mother hela but how early
of an age well if this new silvi
featurette marvel studios just dropped
as any indication it's probably when
sylvie was just little sylvie jr you
know around the time that she was
arrested by the tva
possibly from rebelling against her role
as being merely a tool to be used for
hela's greedy benefit because as we
learn from the tva animation the tva
will arrest
anyone for even the smallest of
deviations from the time keepers plans
like being late for work so a scenario
like this
is quite likely in my opinion those
mothers are probably kidnapping kids all
the time
i mean what are they yondu
and so when little silly loki junior was
declared guilty for breaking out of her
timekeeper destined fate to be a foil
for greater heroes i'm speculating that
she could have used
some of that hella training to kill her
first tva guards
and steal her first 10 pack i mean she
was a child after all and children
are often underestimated if you look
back to the first episode of loki mobius
stops the tva agents from
killing the kid in the church so the tva
do tend to treat
children with a little bit more leniency
but not much
and that's all little silly loki jr
needed to kill her first tva agents get
the back out of there
and then from there she's been on the
run ever since teaching herself magic
along the way to help her survive i mean
sure she's free from her destiny as hell
is war dog but sylvie cannot truly be a
master of her own fate until she can
bring down the time keepers
since they are the slavers of the
multiversal fates which is probably why
she changes her name in the first place
i mean she did discover that there was a
multiverse of loki's tied to the same
wheel of fate by these timekeepers so
what better way to reject the timekeeper
story of the loki's than to reject the
name altogether but that's just my
theory what do you guys think do you
think hella could be sylvie's mother or
do you think sylvie has a different past
let us know below my nerd babies but
anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
mastertainment if you want to see me
tweet or post weird things on twitter
and instagram
but most importantly follow new
rockstars wherever we are especially on
youtube and twitter and if you follow us
on youtube make sure to hit the
notification bell so you can get
notifications whenever we upload a new
video
and don't forget to check out our dope
loki [ __ ] at newrockstarsmerch.com
especially our loki ladies obsession
shirt that isn't going to be around
forever it's called loki out of time and
you
are running out of time to get it so get
to it but yes thank you guys for
watching and i'll see you guys next time
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you